this is a production of Cornell
University
I lost identity Jeremy Pargo
he's from Westeros we marketed bona fide
earn bodily and improper graduates in a
couple weeks
Jeremy could go on to a ph.d program in
college at Michigan State which is great
instead our kind of transition
regulation of drugs is from our clothes
and amazed and population transcend time
this is a tiny bit of his data we really
like to work with you see within this is
like a creates deep pockets so thank you
as Mike said my name is Jeremy and I for
the last couple years have been working
on my honors thesis under the
supervision of Ed buckler and turn
barley and so what I really wanted to do
is look at how the transcriptome is
involved in regulating stomata closure
see how this works
there we go so let's choose the computer
because it works better and so what I
want to do is look at these three
aspects of how a plant works so the
physiology and then the transcriptomic
so mrna and then try and integrate that
together with some genetic mapping to
really get at how stomata closure under
drought is working and so what is this
d'amato closure that i'm talking about
so stow mates are pores on leaves and
plants can close them in response to
water stress to limit water loss but by
closing them they also limit
photosynthesis so it's a trade off and
the plant hormone up sighs gasps 'add is
very much involved in mediating this
response however that hormone is also
really important in controlling other
genetic responses to drought and I
should mention that there are drought
response mechanisms that are independent
of obsessive casted for example the
hormone ethylene plays a major role too
but for today I'm going to focus on
absurd gas 'add and so the plant
material that I used for my experiments
was taken from the maze nested
Association mapping population and the
lines that you see up on your screen are
the founders of the of this population
and so it's 27 in bread corn lines from
around the world that sort of represents
the diversity of maize as best as you
can with 27 lines and then you see the
two that are highlighted in red were the
parents for the mapping population for
that portion of my experiment I mean so
I conducted two separate experiments one
I'll refer to as the quantitative trait
mapping experiment and the other as the
RNA sequencing experiment
and for both of them I group plants for
three weeks and then I took the
seedlings and I start to drought stress
then and so for the quantitative trait
mapping experiment on what I called a
zero so I had three week old plants they
were well watered and I started
measuring some physiological traits and
then by day one I stopped watering them
and I kept measuring those traits each
day and finally on day four of that
experiment irie watered them and then
measured again see how the plants
responded and for the RNA sequencing
experiment it was a very similar design
but here I had two groups so the control
group was always well watered and the
drought stress group very similar so day
zero they're well watered plants and by
day one I withheld water and they're
starting to become drought stressed and
on day one and day three of that
experiment I collected leaf tissue to do
RNA sequencing and so those
physiological measurements here's just
an example of some of the things I
measured so the white little clamp
device is a called a parameter and it
measures the model conductance so it's
basically measuring the flow rate
through this dough mates which is a
measure of how open they are so the more
open the skull mates
general the less drought stress the
plants are and then the other device on
there the little prongs is not a torture
implement it's a soil electrical
conductivity meter and then so I use
that to measure the water content of the
soil to get an idea of how drought
stress my plants actually were and then
for RNA sequencing I used a method that
was adapted to plants by Carl Kremmling
to do 3-prime RNA sequencing and
basically all you need to know about
that is it's a way to cheaply and
quickly profile the RNA from a whole
bunch of samples
yeah okay so back to this physiology
mRNA and genetic mapping so first I'm
going to discuss the physiological
results that I got and so this graph is
showing the still model conductance of
those NAMM parents and the red boxes are
the control groups so those were always
well watered and the blue boxes are my
drought stress treatment so I withheld
water from that when you can see is by
day one of my experiment there's a
significant decrease in stomata
conductance in the drought stress group
but you might also see that there's
still a lot of variation on day one
between genotypes and so this spot is
very similar it's just showing the data
the same trait the stromal conductance
but in my quantitative trait mapping
experiment and again by day one of the
experiment there's a significant
decrease in stomata conductance but
there is also still a lot of variation
between genotypes I'm going to look a
little bit at that variation between
genotypes so this plot is showing the
ratio of stomatal conductance on day one
to day zero for all of those lines in my
RNA sequencing experiment I think the
battery and this is dead so the pointer
won't work but what you can see is that
yes there's a lot of variation within
genotypes but also between genotypes so
the red line represents a ratio of one
so that would mean that there is no
change between day zero and day one and
anything below that line means that the
stomatal conductance decreased anything
above that line would mean that it
increased and see that basically all of
the genotypes are decreasing their
stomata conductance but some of them are
right around that red line whereas some
of them have decreased dramatically
already by day one
so to sum up my physiological results I
found that thermal conductance decreases
significantly under drought stress but
there is a lot of variation between
genotypes and so to sort of get at what
that variation means I wanted to look at
the transcriptional control of this
so I started wading into my RNA seek
data and so what this plot is showing is
that it's a principal component analysis
and so what that is is a way of reducing
very high dimensional data down into two
dimensions so you can put it on a grass
and sort of make sense of it and so all
of the points in purple are the day
three drought conditions in green are
the day 1 drought conditions and then
red and blue are the control samples and
we can see is that on day 3 there's sort
of a cluster all the way over on this
side of the graph whereas the controls
are on the opposite side and the day 1
samples their expression is somewhere in
between and so basically the gene
expression of my samples is clustering
by treatment and that kind of leads me
to believe that the treatment is having
a major effect on that gene expression
and so when I look at genes that were
differentially expressed between the
control group and the drought stress
group on day one of the experiment what
I found is a lot of enrichment for genes
that are involved in stress tolerance so
this makes sense it seems that the
plants are responding to drought stress
which is what I was hoping and then to
go from sort of general overviews of the
expression to highly specific one gene
and so this plot is showing the
expression of the rate-limiting enzyme
in upsizing acid biosynthesis
what you can see is that on both days
during drought stress it is
significantly more expressed than under
controlled conditions and so that
suggests to me that if the plant is
upgrading and lighting the expression of
an ABA biosynthesis enzyme that is
probably producing more obsessive acid
and so as I mentioned earlier absurd
gases is really important in a model
closure and it works through this
complicated signal transduction pathway
that ends in stomata closure
at the end of it but what's interesting
highlighted in that red box is a protein
phosphatase and what that does is it
negatively regulates the episodic acid
signaling pathway and so this is the
expression of just one of those protein
phosphatase genes it's actually a whole
family and I found that nine of them
were differentially expressed under
drought and this is just one of them
which has already been shown to be
important negative regulator of that
pathway and interestingly it's also
expressed more under drought so the
plant is making more up Cizek acid but
it's also making more of a negative
regulator of the episodic acid signaling
pathway and so I wanted to know like
what is coordinating this like delicate
balance between the negative regulation
of this pathway and the up regulation of
the pathway and so the answer I think
lies in transcription factors and so I
looked at all of the transcription
factors that were differentially
expressed under drought and I found that
there were 500 different transcription
factors that were differentially
expressed that lian at least one of the
days under drought stress and what I did
is correlate their expression pattern
with the stomata conductance and I found
that 30 of them are significantly
associated with stomata
duck dents and then among those I had
enrichment for these two general
families of transcription factors so the
heat-shock transcription factor family
and the B zip transcription factor
family and so heat-shock transcription
factors are known to be involved in a
stress response and the B zip family is
one of the largest transcription factor
families in plants but there's a subset
of them that are very important in
regulating of size of casted related
processes so I thought I'd look at those
a little more and so this is just one
example of one of the VSIP transcription
factors that was differentially
expressed under drought and you can see
that on both day 1 and on day 3 and
there's much higher expression and so
this B zip 68 is regulated by AB Cizek
acid and what it does is it controls
chlorophyll degradation and how is that
related to drought well under drought
stress as I mentioned the still might
still meets clothes and that limits
photosynthesis but it doesn't affect how
light is absorbed by chlorophyll and
that results in damage and so one of the
responses that the plant has is to
degrade some chlorophyll to limit the
damage okay so that was really
interesting hopefully but I want to
integrate that a little more with what
is controlling a stomata conductance and
so I looked at my genetic mapping data
and if you remember that was a separate
experiment using a population that was
derived from two of those parents where
I had RNA sequencing data for and so I
looked on both day 1 and day 3 and try
to correlate to model conductance with
genetic markers and so this is a
Manhattan plot and each dot represents a
marker and so we hire the lot the dots
are above the line the more associated
they are with the stomatal conductance
and what I found is that I had a
significant region of the genome on
chromosome 8 that was significantly
associated with stomatal conductance on
day one then when I looked at day 3 I
found something similar again I had one
really peak on there that stands out and
this time it was on chromosome 2 and so
now that have these transcriptional data
and the physiological data as well as
this genetic mapping data I want to look
at how this all comes together so the
intersection of all of these aspects of
the plant some growth in physiology and
so what I did is look in my RNA
sequencing data which if you remember is
a separate experiment but I looked in
the regions that were significantly
associated with stomata conductance from
the genetic mapping experiment and so on
day one I did find that there were genes
differentially expressed but
unfortunately there uncharacterized
proteins so we have no idea what they do
and so I'm not going to talk about them
any further today feel free to ask me
about them later but on day three there
were two genes within that chromosomal
region on chromosome 2 that was
significantly associated with thermal
conductance that were awful
differentially expressed under drought
and so one of them in particular is this
HPA 22 like protein and so what that is
as you can see is differentially
expressed under drought and it's
expressed more under drought stress but
if you look at those little red and blue
dots which are the parents of that
mapping population it's kind of hard to
see but on under control conditions
there are sort of opposite ends of the
expression spectrum and they don't seem
to be at opposite ends under drought
stress but at least under control
conditions there seems to be a big
difference between my two parents and
this gene is differentially expressed
under drought and so what is in barley
this hvae 22 is a program cell death
inhibitor that is responsive to the
hormone up Cizek acid and so the way
seed germination and barley works is
there's a layer of seed called the
aileron layer and when seed germinates
there's programmed cell death and a
bunch of enzymes are released that
degrade the seed coat and you see the
unfortunately this pointer is not
working but if you look at the middle
box on the bottom there you see that you
have these circles with nothing in them
because basically the cell has died and
all of the goop has been released but
when you have over expression of the hva
22 protein you can see that the cell is
not dead and it looks the same as the
control conditions and so this gene is
inhibiting programmed cell death and so
I am hypothesizing that and leaves this
HPA 22 like protein might inhibit
program cell death that's involved in
senescence which we know is triggered in
part by drought stress so just to sum up
what I've told you so far the key aba
biosynthesis gene is differentially
expressed under drought and it's up
regulated but so are negative regulators
of the episodes gas and signaling
pathway and my best candidate for the
chromosomal region that was associated
with still model conductance is an
obsessive casted responsive protein that
seems to be an inhibitor of program cell
death and so in the future what I'm
going to do this summer is look for
common motifs in the promoters of all of
the genes
I found that were differentially
expressed under drought and hope to find
it like these sequences that are
associated with a binding of
transcription factors that maybe are
controlling drought tolerance and so
finally I would like to thank everybody
who made this project possible
so especially my two advisors Ed buckler
and Taryn barley Prestonsburg Jeremy
during an experiment where a dry down
cycle has been limited spots long
sometimes what can happen is that lines
that just generally are run that have
very low rates of photosynthesis any low
the model conductances will remain well
hydrated even after three days while the
ones that are really healthy in are
transpiring rapidly deplete the water
very quickly and then you can get from
some toy to interpretate or like that I
was wondering whether you feel that your
system
some lines that couldn't have those
kinds of variations control so there's
definitely that variation and so what I
did to control for that at least for the
genetic mapping experiment I included I
measured plant height and leaf number
and then sort of merge that together
into a leaf area like factor and I
included that in the model when I was
doing the genetic mapping and so that
was my attempt to control for that
however it is still a major problem and
I were to do the experiment all over
again I would probably use a larger pot
volume simply because that would help to
mitigate that factor
[Music]
so um they're actually both up regulated
by day one and so I didn't have a only
had you know two time points so maybe if
I had measured expression every hour
there could have been like more
differences but the way I didn't go into
it but the way that ABA works is it
actually inactivates the PP to see
inhibitor and so one way reasons that
this might be occurring is it's up
regulating the negative regulator so
that as soon as the drought stress goes
away the response can be turned off and
it might be more of a drought recovery
mechanism so that's just a guess this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu